hi i'm christopher hine today we're
going to be talking about
armed grappling and what that is overall
this is going to be a series of videos
we're not going to hit it all today
but a series of videos that we'll be
putting out over the next few weeks
this is for the patreon page first and
foremost it might eventually come out on
youtube but uh it's going to the patreon
page first
um and thank you guys for the support i
really appreciate it so we're going to
start this
kind of from the other end of the
spectrum so when we
when we did the the knife uh heinz knife
system before
we started from at distance and we
talked about what good distances are
and how the attacks come in and all that
stuff and we built down to kind of a
midway point where we start grappling
this time we're going to go from the
other end of the spectrum which is the
worst position possible
and we're going to build back up to a
good position so we'll talk about all
the things you're going to need along
the way
as we do that i'm going to get josh out
here we're going to work for you guys
josh
[Music]
all right so arguably this is the worst
position you're gonna find yourself in
the reason is because he's on top of me
so that's bad news
and in addition he's got both of his
hands free um so it's bad now i do have
both of my hands free a worse position
could be i could face down
um we're not gonna address that position
in this video but for for rough
approximation this is the worst position
okay now when you're in a
grappling situation that's not a known
situation meaning i'm not in a
tournament or wrestling with my buddy or
whatever
first thing i need to do is assess a
weapon is there a weapon right which
means
when i find myself here and hopefully
long before i found myself here
i'm gonna assess does he have a weapon
in either hand or does he possibly have
a weapon in his waistband that i can
that he could get to right so that's
what i have to do is assess is there a
weapon
if i see a weapon in his waistband i'm
gonna try to go for it first right so
if i see anything if he had a gun a
knife whatever and i see it i'm going
for it the second i see it because
if he gets it it's real bad for me so
weapon assessment and weapon control
is more important than this than
position so don't just immediately try
to get him off i could knock this guy
off and he could shoot me or stab me so
i have to assess the weapon first so i'm
going to scan the hands
takes half a second scan scan anything
in those hands
or is there anything in his waist if
there's anything in his waist i'm going
to go for it first
and at least by getting my hands on
there even if he gets his hands down
at least we're struggling over the
weapon right here as opposed to
him moving the weapon all around and
that's bad news okay so first thing i'm
gonna do is assess that weapon
second thing so now let's say i've
assessed it and let's say he has a
weapon in a hand
okay i need to get control of that
weapon hand so i have to do that somehow
so i'm gonna try and do the simplest
thing possible i'm gonna try and reach
out and grab that hand
now when you grab it this grab is not
any good
because all he's gonna do is switch it
over to the other side immediately so
anytime i'm grabbing
grabbing an arm hand i have to grab the
hand and cover
this opening in the hand at the same
time right so i grab it and then i cover
this opening
now the reason i cover is if he opens
his hand to switch it comes into my hand
that's fantastic
but no matter what if i can keep those
fingers closed he can't open his hand to
switch it himself
so it's really good for me so i have one
hand here controlling the wrist
and one hand controlling the opening of
the hand now look it could be any way
there's no special super great way to do
that any way possible that's what i'm
going to do
okay so i've assessed there's a weapon i
go to get the weapon all right so now
when i get let me go to this hand real
quick
so now when i go to get that weapon if
he's paying attention at all
he is going to pull it away from my
grasp like this okay
now the second he does that i don't want
to just stay
engaged with just my hands so if he
pulls back and he goes like this this is
just a modified fence on the ground
i don't want to stay here because i'm
probably not going to get it he's going
to pull it out of my grip every time so
there he goes pulls it out and then he's
going to stab me and he's going to hunt
and pick it
i'm going to get stabbed in the hands of
it seven the body seven in the head it's
all bad for me right
so at this point what i want to start to
do is try and get my feet in if i can so
that'd be great if i can get my feet in
that'd be magnificent to do that
okay if i can't get my feet in what i'm
going to try and do is disturb his
balance right
so i'm going to put my elbows into his
thighs here and i'm going to push my
hips up now what i want
is that that's what i'm looking for
right now i should do it explosively
so hopefully that'll help me get him
down but that's the idea is i wanna i
wanna
knock him down now when i knock him down
i could shoot out and grab this hand
because now it's here for me right so i
can control the hand
so i shoot out to grab the hand now i'd
recommend in this situation
grabbing the hand in the grossest way
possible so you want to shoot your hands
out and grab it and control it in like
this
now there's a problem there because i
don't have that controlled directly so
he can switch
but when i'm here i can now find it if
we're like this and i immediately try to
go just for the hand it's likely he's
going to pull it back before i get it
so the second those arms go down i want
to control grossly as much as possible
and then as quick as possible
start to work to this hand and get the
hand right so that's the next thing i'm
going to do so all right so he's got on
top of me i assess is there a weapon
in this situation there's a weapon in
that hand i'm gonna try to grab it
i can't grab it can i get my foot in to
stop him from stabbing me now look
this isn't an all-day thing but it
stopped him from stabbing him for a
second
and i'll show you some sweeps and things
we can do from this position if we get
it but i've roughly suppressed the
weapon now
if i can't get that right so maybe he's
pulling his arm over that or something
else
when that weapon's free i'm gonna put my
elbows into his
thighs here and i'm gonna push my hips
up to knock him down like this okay
now the second he hits the ground i'm
going to try and shoot up grab a hold of
this arm
and then work my way to get better
control the hand okay so
this is all in an ideal situation it's
probably not going to happen as nicely
as this but that's the way you're
thinking it's the process you're
thinking through when you're doing this
okay now i have to have weapon control
before i can do anything okay so my
basic ideas are could i just grab the
hand
could i get my foot in to control or
could i trap an arm up here by knocking
him down
those are the ways i'm going to work it
when i get a hold of the hand directly i
want to make sure i always have one hand
covering his fingers here like this so
that's what i'm looking for now from
here
it is possible to disarm and i'm going
to try to disarm and see if i can get it
from this
now disarming is a real simple process
i'm either going to turn his hand this
way
to lengthen all these ligaments and make
his grip weak or i'm going to turn his
hand this way to lengthen all these
ligaments and make his hand weak
that's basically it now there are more
ways to do it than this but these are
the gross ways that you're going to use
most of the time
this way we call number one in aikido we
call this a kodagaish but it's i just
call it a number one because it's the
primary way you're going to get
this way in aikido we call inikyo this
is called the number two right so
simple so i'm either gonna work one or
two generally if i'm trying to work one
and he doesn't like it he turns his hand
he'll turn it into two
if he doesn't like the two and he turns
his hand he'll turn it into one so i'm
usually working one and two as
completory opposites we'll talk about
complicatory opposites pretty soon
so i'm going to work those two back and
forth now if i'm working my number one
what i want to do is i here's my grip
block my basic grip lock here
i'm going to crawl this hand over here
and grab the hand as much of the handle
the knife as i can
i'm going to pull it like this now
that'll already start to weaken his grip
on the knife
then i'm going to take this side and i'm
going to push the knife okay and that's
our number one
so we're here like this i crawl crawl
crawl grab that
that uh handle the knife here and i pull
it a little bit that's gonna start to
break it then we use this hand to push
it the rest of the way through that's my
number one
okay if he turns it the other way i'm
gonna use my hand on this side
to push the handle the knife and we use
this to drive the handle this way so our
the yeah the handle this way so i drive
it up boom and pop it out so we're here
like this
if he turns it the other direction this
goes straight up this goes into the
knife
and you see there's my disarm that way
right now i'll be working those back and
forth
now he's probably going to get his other
hand involved i'm going to have all
kinds of trouble with that and not be
able to simply
pop this free right so it's not going to
not going to be an easy pop out but
that's one of the things we're
struggling over so
once i have it can i start to disarm
right i'm either gonna turn that number
one
or turn that number two now we're going
to go into detail on those more later
for you guys
but i'm just giving you a gross summary
of what's going on here okay now
while i'm getting that understand that i
have this side of his body controlled
so after i have control the weapon i can
start to work position
so a i assess where is the weapon b
i control or suppress so i have some
some way of keeping that weapon from
working
freely to attack me then after that how
do i get a position change right so this
position
sucks for me i want to escape this
position what are my basic
position escapes going to be well i have
this hand already trapped
so i'm going to try to nudge him that
way because he can't base his hand out
right
if he had this hand available to him and
i bud nudged him that way he would put
that hand down like this
okay but when i have the here and i try
and do that he's got to try and reach
across
all kinds of other stuff it's going to
be hard for him okay now he also has
this leg here that he can post out so if
i push him that way he could shoot that
leg out like that to stop me from
throwing him over
so what i'm going to try and do is
control one whole side of his body i'm
going to drop this leg over his legs as
much as i can i'm going to hold this as
much as i can i'm going to push my hips
up as high as i can
i'm going to roll him over into this
position that's what i'm looking for
okay and that's our position change
which is real good for me so there's
lots of ways to do those escapes i'm
gonna make more videos for you guys
just on those specific scapes but here's
our progression that we're using right
one
assess is there a weapon anywhere so one
is waste so one in his hands
okay can i get a hold of it or suppress
it in some way
okay if i can't do that just off the bat
i'm gonna try to make him lose his
balance by putting my hips
or my elbows in his thighs here push up
to make him lose his belt
shoot out grossly grab this arm and then
work over here to this i'm going to show
you a whole series for that because
there's a lot of little things that can
happen in that situation now once i have
control of this hand
i'm going to try and knock him that way
i'm going to do it by covering this leg
so he can't sit it out
and then i'm going to up my hips as high
as i can and i'm gonna pop them over and
that's what we're looking for
all right so all right so that's the
basic summary of what we're gonna be
doing on the ground right
one assess a weapon is there a weapon
anywhere and that's what you should be
doing in a real life situation right so
a non-known situation a known situation
is looking meet my friends to wrestle
or i'm in a tournament or something you
know that there's no weapon involved and
if there is a weapon involved there are
other people there who are going to take
care of it for you so you don't have to
do that but
in a real life situation you never know
when there's going to be a weapon
involved right
now i would also say assess if there's
other people
but because he's on top of us on the
ground it doesn't matter if you've
assessed other people they're coming in
anyway so so you need to deal with the
guy on top of you right now and then we
can get to the other person but from
where you're at now it's really going to
make no
tactical difference so you don't really
need to assess what else is going on
other than you know maybe we're near
rolling off a cliff or into traffic or
something terrible so
so uh the first thing i got to do is
assess the weapon situation right so
where's where's the weapon if there's
one in his waste
i want to control it there's one hand i
want to get it that leads us to step two
suppress or control the weapon now that
means if i could just reach out and grab
it i'll reach out and grab it if i can
stick my foot in to keep him from
stabbing me
or suppress him in some other way catch
his elbow to keep him from stabbing me
that's what i would do
if those aren't working for me i can't
just immediately grab it
i'm going to try and make him lose his
balance by sticking my elbows in pop my
hips up
and then once that hand hits the ground
i'm going to fish for that hand and then
try and control the hand directly so
that's where i'm working towards now
once i have control can i disarm
i'm probably going to disarm with either
a number one and that's turning the hand
this way right like this
and show you josh like this or a number
two turning the wrist this way right and
we're gonna make more videos talking
about what a one and a two is and all
those things and there's other ones we
can talk about too but
basically i'm roughly going to work that
number one or number two if it comes out
cool now i have the knife and i'm going
to try and get this guy off of me if it
doesn't come out then that's fine at
least i have controlled the weapon i'm
gonna try and get this guy off of me so
that leads us to our next step which is
change position how do i change position
well the first way i'm gonna try to do
that
is just to nudge him to the side i'm
controlling so if i'm controlling his
left hand and his left leg i'm gonna
roll him to his left right so that's the
idea is i'm going to take him to that
direction
now that's not going to work a lot of
times we're going to talk about all the
other things that can happen in that but
this is our basic
overview of what happens if you find
yourself in that rough position assess
control or suppress if you can disarm in
that do so
if you cannot change position right so
that's what we're working towards in
that whole thing
i'm gonna make a bunch more videos for
you guys talking about the details of
this thing but it's our first video and
that's your overall view
of the horrible position i'm christopher
hines joshua t thanks for watching
[Music]